david bonjour alors les manifestants
ont-ils répondu présent à l'appel cet
après midi c'est le cas de le dire
olivier vous le disiez entre 350000 et
quatre cent mille manifestants dans le
cortège selon la cgt selon les syndicats
ils ont tous répondu présents à l'appel
et en cause un puisque le projet de loi
a été présenté au conseil des ministres
avant d'être examiné mi février par
l'assemblée nationale les manifestants
arrivent au compte-gouttes ici 1 place
de la concorde la place de la concorde
qui était littéralement pris été
littéralement possédé un par les
manifestants le cortège est arrivé à peu
près il ya une trentaine de minutes
encerclés par un dispositif de sécurité
assez surréaliste c'est le cas de le
dire un didier lallement avait prévenu
mettre tous les moyens en oeuvre pour
assurer la sécurité des manifestants et
éviter les violences et dégradations en
marge du cortège des violences et
dégradations qui n'ont pas eu lieu
puisque la manifestation s'est passé
dans le calme dans une ambiance plutôt
festive et pacifique
1 daniel et mono à député france
insoumise a également participé à cette
manifestation pour soutenir cette cause
et demander le retrait pur et simple du
projet de loi de réforme des retraites
elle a également parlé des violences
policières je vous propose de l'écouter
en tant que élu député je suis contre ce
projet loi en tant que citoyenne aussi
et puis en tant que salarié enfin hors
de mon mandat de député je suis
bibliothécaire fonctionnaire et je coche
pas mal de cases pour moi même
personnellement être désavantagé par ce
nouveau ce nouveau
cette nouvelle réforme mais plus
globalement parce que c'est un mauvais
projet et la mobilisation qui dure
maintenant depuis plus de 40 jours est
une des plus longues de l'histoire de ce
pays et se développe avec des formes
nouvelles il y avait hier soir des
marches aux flambeaux il ya des actions
des concerts c'est vraiment il ya une
créativité énorme et là on l'a vu dans
cette manifestation qui est jeune qui
est déterminé donc voilà il faut
maintenir la pression parce que c'est il
ya que comme ça que on arrivera à
obtenir le retrait de la mobilisation va
donc se poursuivre en tout cas jusqu'à
temps que le projet de loi de réforme de
retraite va se retirer je vous disais
les manifestants ont pris possession de
la place de la concorde et compte y
rester à un certain moment encore pour
se faire entendre du gouvernement
les manuels macron merci beaucoup david
pour toutes ces précisions david khalifa
en direct de la place de la concorde à
paris